president biden's speech last night it
was his first state of the union address
the president called for unity on a
number of issues including a tough
response to russia's invasion of ukraine
and also on some of the domestic
challenges facing the country so how did
it go over that is the question on this
morning after well 78 of americans who
watch the speech approved of it that's
according to our cbs news poll but we do
need to point out that close to half of
those polled are democrats and o'keefe
is at the white house with more on the
story ed good morning to you on this
morning after good morning gayle it is
always great to see you here in
washington welcome back to town it was a
62-minute speech during which the
president mostly tried to dwell on
common ground and not on the
partisanship that's divided this capital
city and from the beginning he focused
on an issue that's quickly become a top
of mind concern the crisis in ukraine
and holding vladimir putin accountable
he has no idea what's coming
president biden spent the first 10
minutes of his state of the union
address condemning russian president
vladimir putin's attack on ukraine he
thought he could roll into ukraine and
the world would roll over
instead
he met with a mall a wall of strength he
never anticipated or imagined he met
ukrainian people
surrounded by lawmakers wearing the blue
and yellow colors of ukraine and waving
that country's flag the emotional high
point of the night came when he
introduced ukraine's ambassador
thank you
the president announced plans to close
u.s airspace to russian planes and said
the justice department will be joining a
global campaign to root out russian
oligarchs with ties to putin we're
joining with european allies to find and
seize their yachts their luxury
apartments their private jets
we're coming for you ill-begotten gains
mr biden appeared without a mask and got
up close and personal with kali let's
use this moment to reset
so stop looking at coven as a partisan
dividing line according to a cbs news
poll of speech watchers 64 percent said
the president's policies would lower
inflation
one way to cut costs he said would be to
revitalize american manufacturing that
means make more cars than semiconductors
in america
more infrastructure and innovation in
america
more goods moving faster and cheaper in
america he pushed a pathway to
citizenship for dreamers and distanced
himself from liberal democrats on
criminal justice reform the answer is
not to defund the police
it's to fund the police
fund
he also called for passage of a unity
agenda focused on four issues with broad
bipartisan support beating the opioid
epidemic tackling mental health
supporting veterans and ending cancer
but his attempts at bipartisanship were
punctured by two republican lawmakers
marjorie taylor greene of georgia and
lauren bober of colorado
they shouted build the wall when he
mentioned immigration and bobert
interrupted again when he was speaking
of his son's death blaming the president
for service members killed in
afghanistan during last year's chaotic
withdrawal
[Music]
that drew booze from across the chamber
and the two congresswomen were
criticized overnight by members of both
parties as for today the president is
going to continue the tradition of going
on the road to amplify his message the
first lady will join him in wisconsin
where they'll talk about the
infrastructure bill passed last year and
other domestic agenda items the white
house says he'll also be closely
monitoring the situation in ukraine
gail
thank you